what is the stress test for banks a bank
is shaken and inspected for holes in its
capital to determine whether it's
healthy and whether its foundation is
strong 130 banks in the eurozone are
being submitted to a battery of
financial tests 25 of these banks are
from Germany the testers are from the
European Central Bank they're inspecting
the banks balances to do this they make
the assumption that a heavy crisis
strikes the financial world stock prices
collapse people default on loans for
homes and companies and prices on goods
and services for the entire gross
domestic product slumps for two years
the auditors evaluate whether the bank
could survive such a crisis or whether
it would collapse to cushion loan
defaults a bank needs funds of its own
what is called its core capital ratio
must never fall below 5.5 percent if the
simulated crash leaves the bank with
less than that then the bank has failed
but it still has one last chance if it
can plug the holes in its core capital
but how does it do that it could issue
additional shares in itself or sell old
shares if that isn't enough the state
could intervene
but if a bank chronically fails to meet
its requirements it has to close no
matter how big it is the european
central bank wants healthy banks in
Europe after all it will soon be in
charge of supervising banks